[upbeat music]
Sharon Rechter:
My partner Guy Oranim and I
started BabyFirst
with the idea and a passion
to create good
educational content
for babies, toddlers,
and their parents.
Today we have over 30 million
downloads for BabyFirst apps.
When we learned about
the family category
on the GooglePlay store,
it was a hundred percent match
to the BabyFirst values,
because a BabyFirst app
will always have a family value
to allow a child and a parent
to interact
and it will always have
age-appropriate content.
We have seen that parents
can easily find
the content
they are looking for.
We now have 40% more downloads
on GooglePlay
than we do on other platforms.
We like that.
Yuval Rechter: The store listing
experiments tool
really allows us to know
what works in the store,
which icon works,
which video works,
which screenshot works.
For the first time,
we can actually test it
with real Android users,
just knowing--and 100% almost--
what actually works.
And that's what we like.
It's a drag-and-drop.
You can allocate
some of the traffic
to the new experiment.
So the risk is low.
The benefit is high.
In "ABC," for example,
when we tested the icons,
we tried to do a darker icon
or a brighter icon.
In the icon itself,
different colors.
We tried to do two-dimensional
or three-dimensionals,
and actually see
what works better for the user
and what is more visible.
After running the experiments
on the "ABC" app,
we saw 140% increase
in the downloads.
It was great.
[upbeat music]
In the "Play Phone" app,
we tested screenshots.
We implemented an image of a
phone in the screenshot itself.
We played with text,
with colors, with shapes.
And this resulted in an increase
of 11% in organic downloads.
[upbeat music]
Another simple thing
that we have done,
we have localized our store
listing page in ten languages.
This resulted in an increase
of 150% in organic downloads
outside the U.S.
Through a combination of
store experiments,
the family category,
localization,
we're able to see
a 50% increase in downloads
across our portfolio.
Sharon: I think
we're super lucky.
We get to work
on something we love.
We make kids happy
every single day.
Now we intend to offer
even better apps for kids
but also talk to the moms,
because we have their trust
right now
and want to help make
moms' life easy.
We're super excited
about the future,
because the model works
and we can't wait for it.
[upbeat music]